11h bruno girveau entraîneur et
compétiteurs licenciés au club trans maj
arrive au centre aquatique du lamentin à
peine le temps de poser de la terre
qu'il se retrouve déjà à l'eau pour les
consignes du jour d'ailleurs de
papillons il ya deux fois cinq ans vous
cramer pas c'est vraiment amplitude ce
matin les nageurs de catégorie maître
présent travail l'amplitude et la
résistance face à l'effort dans moins de
trois jours ils devront tout donner pour
les championnats de france qui se
dérouleront ici dans ce bassin chauffé
la france à martinique
ses motivations maximum voilà on a déjà
le trac pas pensé mon lot l'acte plus de
l'excitation
un challenge d'autant plus relevée pour
cette catégorie de nageurs âgés de 25 à
95 ans où l'amour de la natation
l'emportent sur les obligations du
quotidien pas évident de d'allier vie
familiale vie professionnelle et
entraînements mais on essaie de faire au
mieux et puis surtout c'est une manière
d'encourager les jeunes ceux qui nagent
en club on aura vraiment leur dire qu'on
peut tout donner mais dans la
convivialité le plaisir l'amour du sport
surtout l'amour de natation un amour du
sport stimulée par la compétition à
l'entraînement bruno me lâche jamais son
chrono
les performances sont décrits pied afin
de hisser les nageurs au summum de leur
potentiel
on essaie de reproduire la vitesse de
course qu'ils vont faire dans trois
jours en fait donc vraiment faire les
derniers derniers réglages très très
faim donc voir s'il n'anticipe pas s'ils
sont vraiment réaction vraiment active
voilà ont toutes les déperditions les
élimine la à ce petit jeu les rivalités
au sein du club sont utiles elles
permettent à chacun et à chacune de se
surpasser et d'aller chercher les
meilleures performances dans la bonne
humeur
ça fait toujours quelque chose pour
qu'on se rend compte sous les plots donc
on verra l'arrivée au temps et au
classement et nos 70 qualifiez vous
donne rendez vous ce jeudi au centre
aquatique du lamentin pour les relais
qui danseront les premières épreuves des
championnats de france m de natation